Clara macido is a middle-aged woman
looking for a job as a nanny in the
opening scene she arrives at Anna's home
for an interview it is revealed that
Anna is pregnant with a child but she
has no immediate family members to take
care of her so she wants Clara to stay
at the apartments at all times the
latter agrees right away but when the
interview commences her responses aren't
that good it's evident that she doesn't
have any experience in taking care of
the babies this disappoints Anna
slightly but she decides to give the
woman a chance as they are talking Anna
suddenly gets a sharp pain in her
stomach and starts to panic she fears
that she is going to pass out but Clara
quickly Springs into action and uses a
shoulder rubbing technique that eases
her pain this finally impresses Anna and
she announces that Clara has secured the
job she also gives the woman a house to
her saying she can eat whatever she
wants at any time from the very next
morning Clara gets to work and does all
her tasks diligently she cares for the
house as if it is her own in the evening
while cleaning Anna's room she discovers
pistol in a drawer however Clara puts it
back and doesn't think much of it
several days go by during which the two
get closer and start living like best
friends Clara helps Santa with
everything and never leaves her side
they even go to the hospital together
for Anna's monthly checkup the doctor
claims that the baby is a boy and is
perfectly healthy much to her Delight a
few days later Clara walks up to Anna
drinking and dancing alone the latter
reveals that it is her birthday but none
of her family members have called her it
turns out that Anna was supposed to
marry a man but she got pregnant with
someone else's child her father brought
her to the city forcing her to get an
abortion but she refused to do so since
then her mother along with all of her
family and friends have cut ties with
her her wedding also got canceled and
she moved to the city Anna says that she
doesn't care about them anymore but
Clara senses her Sadness the two then
talk for a while and drown their Soros
at her next doctor's appointment Santa
is informed that her blood pressure is
higher than usual so she should cut meat
from her diet following that Claire only
Cooks vegetarian meals for her she also
checks in his blood pressure every day
to make sure she is healthy one night
Clara leaves Anna on her own for the
first time and goes to get a drink when
she returns Anna is in front of the
refrigerator looking for something to
eat as she gets closer and it starts to
kiss her passionately Clara freezes in
shock when suddenly Anna bites her and
scratches her back the confused maid
quickly Retreats and sees the blood is
all over in his face the shocking thing
is that the pregnant woman doesn't utter
a word and simply goes to her room
following morning and it doesn't
remember anything that happened the
previous night she simply carries on
with her day as if nothing has happened
Clara also doesn't say a word assuming
her mistress was just sleepwalking as
the two engage in small talk Anna
reveals that she has chosen the name
Joel for her son some days later Clara
is making a pregnancy chart when she
realizes that Anna's sleepwalking could
have a connection with the facts it was
a full moon night time passes and on the
next full night Anna wakes up covered in
sweat because of a nightmare Clara comes
to her side to help her but the two
strangely get attracted to one another
and start making out once they are done
they fall asleep in the same bed at
midnight Anna abruptly opens her eyes
which have turned light brown she gets
up and starts to sleep walk again this
time Clara doesn't stop her instead she
follows her outside Anna slowly exits
the house and walks through the streets
she only comes to a halt when she sees a
cat in front of her what she does next
makes clora screech in Terror Anna
attacks
and devours it alive the next morning
she once again doesn't remember a thing
and acts as if everything is fine but
Clara knows that she is dangerous and
can pounce at any time so in order to
keep Anna at Bay she cuts her palm and
pours blood into her breakfast the
pregnant mistress devours the dish in an
instant claiming it is delicious she
appears to be drawn towards Flesh and
Blood after a while Clara finally brings
up in a sleepwalking habit and reveals
that she attacked her last month this
makes Anna burst into tears so Clara
decides to not talk about the cat she
then explains that these things are
common during pregnancy and it will
eventually go away I don't know about
that one at night Clara pours flower
around Anna's bad so that she can know
if she sleepwalks but to her Delight she
wakes up in the morning and notices that
the flower hasn't moved Clara is now
sure that Anna doesn't have any sleep
disorder and she only sleepwalks on Full
Moon nights later that day the two sing
a lullaby together as they talk Anna
opens up about the father of her son she
was on vacation last year when she met a
man named George she instantly felt
drawn to him and at the end of the night
went on a drive with him the two got
intimate with each other but the next
morning she woke up alone in the car
while looking for George she saw a pair
of glowing eyes in the dark Curious
George scared she shot at the creature
with a pistol she found in George's car
it ran away to the woods and she
returned home after finding out that she
is pregnant and I went back to look for
him but no one in the town knew who
George was eventually she gave up and
returned home as Anna finishes up her
story she becomes emotional so Clara
Comforts her once again following this
we are taken to the next full moon night
where Anna suddenly starts whimpering in
pain because of a terrible cramp Clara
quickly calls the doctor but before she
can explain the situation Anna's baby
tears her stomach apart and emerges from
it the impact causes Anna to die
instantly Clara is in shock and doesn't
know what she should do she looks it in
his limp body and then at the boy she
just gave birth to it is clear that the
infant isn't a human being but a
werewolf that has killed its own mother
horrified Clara brings out the pistol
but she cannot bring herself to shoot
the infants since she cannot stay at the
house either she takes the kid with her
and runs away from there at first Clara
plans to throw the werewolf in a ditch
but then her maternal instincts kick in
and she decides against it instead she
brings him to her old house declaring
him her son the movie then jumps to
seven years later Clara has named the
boy Joel as per his biological mother's
wish to suppress his werewolf urges she
has never fed him any kind of meat Clara
also loves him like her own son and is
living a happy life however on every
full moon night she locks him in a
secret room with his hands chained to
the wall the following day Joel always
has a body full of hair and long nails
like a werewolf but they shave
everything off and pretend like nothing
happened they've kept this a secret from
the rest of the world yet the kid is
Curious by Nature he always asks Clara
about his biological mother but Clara
dismisses the matter saying that she
found him by a river one day Clara has
to leave for Urgent work so she asks her
landlady Amelia to babysit Joel for the
day unfortunately the innocent woman
notices that Joel is skinny so without
asking anyone she makes him chicken the
boy consumes it without any hesitation
despite the fact that he is having meat
for the first time when Clara returns
home at night she shockingly sees Joel
with a picture of Anna he apparently
found it in her belongings and is now
questioning her about the person in the
picture Clara nervously makes excuses
saying that she was about to tell him
the truth she then reveals that Anna is
his mother who died while giving birth
hearing this Joel becomes upset as he
was lied to for this long unlike his
usual nature he then starts getting
aggressive and yells at her I don't want
to go to my room this expectedly scares
Clara so she locks him in the secret
bedroom fearing that he will turn into a
werewolf after this she approaches the
landlady and asks what the boy did all
day when Amelia reveals that she fed him
meat Clara finally learns why he has
been acting weird as of late later
Joel's friends Amanda and Mauricio come
to visit him but Clara sends them away
saying that he is asleep she then goes
inside the secret room the next morning
and calmly explains to Joel that he
looks like his mother and has habits
similar to her like Anna he also likes
to dance and sing at this point the boys
calmed down a bit and he curiously asks
about his father but Clara says that she
doesn't know anything about him hearing
this response Joel once again becomes
mad and refuses to talk to her at school
he asks his friend Mauricio to help him
look for his father as the kids are
innocent and inexperienced they decide
to start with the busiest building in
the town the local shopping mall later
when Clara comes to pick Joel up from
school she is shocked to see him missing
she rushes to Mauricio's father and
requires about her child but the man
just says that they must be playing
somewhere Clara gets more worried by the
second because it is a full moon night
and after what happened the day before
Joel has become very dangerous one of
her neighbors suggests that Clara call
the police immediately but she doesn't
do it fearing their secret would be
revealed on the other hand Mauricio and
Joel hide inside the mall until it
closes then get out to look for his
father however since it is a full moon
night Joel unexpectedly turns into a
werewolf and attacks his friend Mauricio
tries to run away through an elevator
but he is eventually caught the poor boy
is then torn into pieces and devoured
completely by the Beast later at night
Joel returns home still in his werewolf
form when Amalia sees him she becomes
frightened and assumes that he is
possessed however Clara mentions that
Joel is a werewolf and that this is his
true form monomalia still doesn't calm
down Clara injects her with an
anesthetic and knocks her out the danger
is averted for the moment but Clara
knows that she cannot stay in the house
for long so she decides to run away with
Joel first thing in the morning
unfortunately the messed up boy foils
her plans once again as he locks her in
the secret bedroom and heads out the
entire day he carries out his usual
routine by attending his classes and
hanging out with his friends at night he
goes to Amanda's place to dance with her
the two have a wonderful time and it
appears as if they are in love with each
other however their happy moment comes
to an abrupt end when Joel begins to
transform at the same time Clara is
finally freed by a stranger she runs to
get her son and finds him about to
attack Amanda without any hesitation
Clara shoots the werewolf in the leg and
brings him back home however as she's
dressing his wound several angry locals
surround the house they have learned
that the boy is a werewolf and that he
is the one who took Mauricio's life as
the locals bang on their door Clara and
Joel hold hands preparing to face them
together the movie ends as Joel lets out
one final howl
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching